here we have the graph or part of the
graph of y is equal to x squared again
and I want to find the volume of another
solid of revolution but instead of
rotating around the x-axis this time I
want to rotate around the y-axis and
instead of going between 0 and some
point I'm going to go between Y is equal
to 1 and Y is equal to 4 so I'm going to
do is I'm going to take this graph right
over here I'm going to take this curve
instead of rotating it around the x-axis
like we did in the last few videos I'm
going to rotate it around the y-axis so
I'm going to rotate it around I'm going
to rotate it around just like that so
what's the shape that we would get let
me see if we can visualize this so the
base is going to look something like
it's going to look something like that
we could see through it look something
like that and then this up here the top
of it would look something would look
something like that it looks something
like that and we care about the stuff in
between so we care about this part right
over here not the very bottom of it and
let me shade it in a little bit so it
would look something it would look
something like that
so let me draw it separately just so we
can visualize it so I'll draw it at
different angles so if I were to draw it
the y-axis kind of coming out the back
it would look something like this it
looks something like it's a little bit
smaller like that and then it gets cut
off right over here right over here like
that so it looks I don't know what
what's shape you could call it but I
think hopefully you're conceptualizing
this let me do that same yellow color
the visual is in that's not yellow the
visualization here is probably probably
the hardest part but as we can see it's
not too bad so it looks something like
looks something like this looks like
maybe a truffle an upside down truffle
so this writer and let me draw the
y-axis just just so we're oriented so
the y-axis is popping out is popping out
in this example like that then it goes
down over here then the x axis the x
axis is going is going like this so I
just tilted this over I tilted it over a
little bit to be a
view it at a different angle this top
right over here this top right over here
is this top right over there so that
gives you an idea of what it looks like
but we still haven't thought about how
do we actually find the volume of this
thing well what we can do instead of
creating disks where the depth is in
little DX is what if we create a disks
where the depth is in dy so let's think
about that a little bit so let's create
let's think about constructing a disk at
a certain Y value so let's go let's
think about a certain Y value we're
going to construct a disk right over
there that has the same radius of the
shape at that point so that's our disk
that's our disk right over here that's
our disk right over there and then it
has a depth instead of saying it has a
depth of DX let's say it has a depth of
dy so this depth right over here is d Y
so what is the volume of this disk in
terms of wine as you can imagine we're
going to do this definite integral it is
a definite integral with respect to Y so
what's the air what's the volume of this
thing well like we did in the last video
we have to figure out the area of the
top of each of these disks or I guess
you could say the face of this coin well
to find that area it's PI R squared if
we can figure out this radius right over
here we know the area so what's that
radius so to think about that radius in
terms of Y we just have to solve this
this this equation explicitly in terms
of Y so instead of saying it's y is
equal to x squared we can take the
principal root of both sides and we
could say that the square root of Y is
equal to X and this right over here is
only defined for non-negative Y's but
that's ok because we are in the positive
x axis right over here so we can also
call this function we can also call this
function right over here X is equal to
the square root of Y and we're
essentially looking at this side of it
we're not looking at we're not looking
at this stuff right over here so we're
only looking at this side right over
here we've now expressed this graph this
curve as X as
function of wise if we do it that way
what's our radius right over here
well our radius right over here is going
to be f of Y it's going to be the square
root of Y it's going to be the square
root of Y is our radius so it's going to
be a function of Y I don't want to
confuse you for if you thought this was
f of X and I think this is f of Y I know
it would be a function of Y we could
call it G of Y it's going to be the
square root of Y so area area is equal
to PI R squared which means that the
area of this thing the area of this
thing is going to be pi times our radius
times our radius squared our radius is
square root of Y our radius is square
root of Y so this thing is going to be
equal to it is going to be equal to is
going to be equal to PI square root of Y
squared is just pi times y now if we
want the volume we just have to multiply
the area of the surface times the depth
times dy so the volume of each of those
disks is going to be PI Y times dy x
times dy this gives you the volume of
the disk volume of a disk now if we want
the volume of this entire thing we just
have to sum all of these disks for all
the Y values between Y is equal to 1 and
Y is equal to 4 so let's do that so we
just take the definite integral from y
is equal to 1 and y equals 4 and just as
a reminder definite integral is a very
special type of sum we're summing up all
of these things but we're taking the
limit of that sum as these d wise gets
get shorter gets I guess squatter and
squat or smaller and smaller and we have
a larger and larger number of these
disks really as these become infinitely
small and we have an infinite number of
discs so that our sum doesn't just
approximate the volume it actually is
the volume at the limit so to figure out
the volume of this entire thing we just
have to evaluate this definite integral
in terms of Y and so how do we do that
well it's going to be equal to what's we
could take the PI outside it's going to
be PI times the antiderivative of Y
which is just Y squared over 2
- y squared over 2 evaluated from 1 to 4
evaluated from 1 to 4 which is equal to
pi times
well you evaluate it for you get 16 over
2 let me just write it out like this 4
squared over 2 minus 1 squared over 2
which is equal to pi times 16 over 2 is
8 minus 1/2 and so we could view this as
16 halves minus 1/2 which is equal to 15
halves so this is equal to 15 halves 15
halves times pi or another way of
thinking about it 7 and 1/2 times 5 this
is a little bit clearer so we're done we
found our volume not rotating around the
x axis but rotating around the y axis
which is kind of kind of exciting